hi i'm hannah this is my dog rosie and
today we're making my favorite food
spaghetti and meatballs inspired by the
new lady in the [ __ ] movie out on
disney plus on november 12th now this
dish is a new take on a timeless classic
much like the movie and i'm so excited
to show you and we can all enjoy it
together
right
[Music]
spaghetti and i have a long history not
to throw my mom under the bus but she
was kind of a health nut when i was
growing up and only made whole wheat
spaghetti and like very very healthy
sauce full of veggies and so that's all
i thought it was it wasn't until
probably a year and a half ago that i
actually tried spaghetti at a restaurant
it was the most delicious thing i'd ever
had the way i like to treat marinara
sauce is just whatever i have in my
pantry kind of goes in now to get the
flavor of basil in the sauce we're just
going to wilt a big bunch in the sauce
and then remove it after it has simmered
for a while
[Music]
now onto the meatballs the fun part i
like to soak the bread crumbs in milk it
makes almost a paste that binds all the
ingredients together my meatball recipe
is very simple as well my take on it is
to add a little bit of fennel but really
it's so customizable it's so easy to
just experiment and try something new
with a meatball and it always tastes
good
a little trick when you're rolling
meatballs is to coat your hands in olive
oil it really helps to prevent sticking
so this will help roll smooth meatballs
and make it a much cleaner process feel
free to follow along with this but it's
fully customizable which is the great
thing about spaghetti there's no right
way to make it and no wrong way to make
it it doesn't have to be perfect it
doesn't have to be pretty as long as the
sides get browned who cares i am so
excited for this movie it's a movie i've
always enjoyed and seeing it in live
action is going to be so adorable and
even better the cast is all rescue dogs
it warms my heart i like a nice ratio of
sauce to spaghetti i do a pretty
generous portion of sauce three
meatballs now i'm adding burrata to this
it's not typically found on spaghetti
but it's the creamiest cheese ever and
it just takes it to the next level it's
so delicious and then some basil leaves
and parmesan and it is ready to eat oh
man i am so excited for this
rosie do you want one
oh man this is good so i set some aside
for rosie should we try a lady in the
[ __ ]
spaghetti moment
[Music]
[Music]
should we watch our movie
[Music]
oh yes